you ready ready good okay ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to your favorite
podcast you know the name and on today's
podcast we got this gonna be a different
one y'all but you can't forget the
singing all right there we go all right
we're done all right welcome to Griffin
with Griffin like I said and today's
guest is it's out there but it's not a
comedian it's not an actor this guy is
an astronaut in training right right
perspective astronaut perspective
astronaut just all around just he's good
dude nerdy rugged nerd that's right give
it up for the this the smartest dude
that's ever been in my probably the
smartest dude on Riverwood grammar give
it up for mr. Dylan Dickstein thank you
sir okay well first of all I just want
to say this you're the first guest to
actually email me like he emailed me
this riffin with Griffin future
astronaut Dylan Dickstein possible
talking points possible talking points
and background info and use it don't use
it whatever you want I just is there for
you if you want it in case I need it huh
if you don't want
no it was like it's actually very
interesting so actually let me just give
some background to the I'm gonna go to
this actually this is a good stuff but
um the first thing is I met Dylan on Lok
and Paul's podcast how's that the
podcast and then you were sitting there
and you know like what do you do and
you're like oh yeah well I want to go to
Mars you know and I was like what what
do you mean you want to go to Mars
then we just started talking and I
thought oh my god I gotta have this
person on my podcast just to talk about
this stuff but first let me ask you this
do you think nerd is a derogatory term
hmm I
yeah is it the other N word definitely
is more mild than dweeb something like
that oh like that definitely has a
negative connotation okay
although nerd is becoming in fashion I
feel like oh you yeah you're seeing
shirts that say be nice to nerds they'll
be your boss one day Rui Rui Rui right
so I think as long as you have a good
outlook then even it's not too bad it
does seem one of the softer of the you
know the make fun of people words I
guess if you if that's the right term I
don't this is it can be derogatory I
guess and how it's used but even even
though all these words can be like that
but somebody's a nerd is like right in
the middle right you know because a lot
of times I'm sure like how often do you
get called a nerd honestly I think you
were the first since high school
keep in mind like where I'm at UCLA I'm
doing my PhD you know you can't just
call everyone a nerdy kind of boring
you're not passing by the biology lab
okay alright so then that's on me but
rugged though that that makes it all
better
well you're not that you're not a
typical nerd you're not like all right
you're right you I mean I mean yeah I'm
not sure what you you know what the
image of nerd is but I'd like to think I
am more sociable yeah no but I just
think it's about like it's like this
kind of stuff you know I mean that you
actually typed it I thought this was
something you had ready but then I
looked at it I thought oh no he actually
took time guys this is almost three
pages that he wrote you know that
wrote to be like hey this is some stuff
you might possibly want to talk about
but you know I remember the first thing
we talked about was like you you know
you wanted to go to you're talking about
you want to go to Mars and it's like why
should we go to Mars right we need a
plan B essentially and it's only the
next step in terms of our exploration as
a humanity okay why do you say we need a
plan B what's what's plan a are you
saying they plan a is Earth's and we're
[ __ ] that up and now it's like we
need to go to someplace else I mean it's
it's not a matter of imminence but but
yeah it's humanity has done way too much
for us just to let natural selection
take us away or our visual selection
eventually if if things go south here on
earth we have an opportunity to to go to
another body and becoming multiplanetary
species and that's just the next
progression for intelligent life and
Mars is is it's not a low-hanging fruit
but it's possible yeah but isn't Mars
the way it is right now what we think
the earth is what we're gonna do to the
earth so why why would we start there
well we should just do it here
your change is there right in terms of
like messing up the earth how we did
like why we'd want to do it to different
planets no no I'm saying
Mars is already messed up there's no
water in a desolate it looks like a
desert
it's crazy no one lives there there's no
life apparently and so we want to go
there and start from scratch when we
could still salvage this one we keep in
mind though earth is a gem we we are one
in a billion there there are other plans
like us somewhere else they're just very
very far away
Oh Mars is is in our reach it's about
1/2 times as far as the Sun is from us
and the Sun is relatively close and so
the the fact that is we have this red
rock sitting right there and it has some
potential of being habitable with with
the right engineering makes it a
something worth fighting for
huh that's so interesting that you say
that I mean I just
I don't know man I just think like like
like how far how far away realistically
are we from being on Mars I'm I think we
miss you we're gonna talk about this a
little bit on an impulsive by 2034 is
the year that I'm saying first boots on
Mars and and that mission will be as
simplistic and short-lived as it can
possibly be it's not short it's a twenty
six month mission total that's just how
long it takes Firth and Mars to a line
but when you say that in terms of a line
you're saying like it's not like we
could just go into space and then the
GPS is like turn right okay so so does
that mean that sounds like a limitation
in space technology then it's it's
actually kind of wild this is pretty
counterintuitive for most people but the
way you travel from body to body in
space is super different than anything
we see on earth oh really
if you'd if you take a left
hypothetically space the amount of
energy you're doing to do that is insane
you you actually travel in arcs like
ellipses and hyperbolas so you're saying
we can't just the space shuttle can't
just go into space and we just go okay
let's turn and then it goes like direct
like the GPS points towards or we
concede on this you know look isn't that
Mars and we can't the lip turns no left
turns so it's not like just space shell
takes off as soon as he hits the
atmosphere out of the atmosphere it
can't just like you can't just look in
in you know just play like oh let's go
this way like you know make it make a
left use ways right if Siri tries to
tell you take a left you're about to use
all your fuel really that why is that
right the the way ultimately you're
going really fast relative to how
anything you're dealing with on earth
when you are in a car
and you're going 65 miles per hour on
the freeway it's actually pretty easy to
get down to a standstill right just put
on the brake and then if you need to
change lanes no problem wait okay then
you step in while you're talking about
this so I can get my accurate my
bracelet okay so okay cuz I think what
you're saying because if you're going 65
miles per hour even at 65 miles per hour
you can't make a left
correct exact if you're on a street
you're going 65 miles per hour you get
to get down to 30 to make a proper left
anyway it's not like you hitting that
turn at 65 like her at 40 or so
sometimes your car might go okay
alright I'm starting to understand nice
and like just just for scaling planes go
about ten times as fast as cars uh-huh
rockets go between ten and twenty or
thirty times as fast as planes oh wow
and so the you kind of like that idea of
like skidding out is it requires just
loss of energy and when you have only so
much fuel and no gas stations in space
you don't want to be making any left
turns so so from so when you take so
when you're the rocket is launching from
Earth it's pretty much by they've
figured out mathematically by the time
it hits outside the atmosphere this is
already a straight line to where we're
going it's it's a it's an art it's okay
making like smooth arcs just because the
distance or so I get what you're saying
but but yeah essentially you can't just
like come to a stop and turn okay now
all right all right so they had the guys
to the this because the space station is
like up there right now right it's it's
you know I have never thought to look
for it look at it for it well at one
point
okay I'm gonna have to okay this main
straight I'm gonna take I'm gonna do a
little video about that but there was
that one guy that was living up there
and then his body started to deteriorate
Scott Kelly Scott Kelly which told me
we're not ready to be in space it's I
mean keep in mind that the J part of the
job of being an astronaut is you are a
test so specimen you you're a lab rat in
a way you're conducting experiments for
a NASA and for anyone else on the on the
earth who wants to test things in
microgravity but it but all these
experiments are also being done on you
any physiological experiment that would
test our readiness to live in space or
to colonize different body what but
isn't the colonizing that's a whole
other other thing where we're talking
about right now is the trip there right
you're right right
and so yeah Kelly spent about a year in
space and he came back and had lots of
issues his uh his legs swell and was
body completely different three
different things when you're in space he
got one Schaller which is funny because
he's a twin so he was taller than his
twin for a little while now dude let me
ask you this did they use his tool did
they use him because he had a twin so
they can actually be like let's see the
differences yeah did they study that his
twin to the David bring his twin in and
go like okay let's take some tests to
both of you and then send him up and
when you come back we're gonna be like
whoa look at these differences hundred
percent I mean Scott and Mark Kelly are
both very talented individuals and it
remains to be seen what they would have
been selected to be astronauts on their
own maybe but certainly as twins that
was a very compelling case for NASA
because they were able to send one of
them namely Scott to space for a long
time and then have mark on the ground
and then have a direct comparison you
know you said it like on in Hollywood
you know you have like a baby on a movie
set right they usually have twins mm-hmm
because you can use one of the other but
it doesn't mean they're the best actor
[Laughter]
okay so would you sign up for something
like that would you be would you be gung
ho to be experimented on to see what
happens to your body in space anyone who
would say no to that is not ready to be
an astronaut oh man he's putting it out
there challenge accepted I mean that's
part of the job description you you need
to be able to be an experimenter
doing more like lab based experiments
for NASA but you also need to be able to
be a big test specimen and and be one of
the few examples that are actually
understanding what microgravity will do
to your body and and quite literally you
will be challenged every day Wow and it
monitored and you seem to be like you're
gung ho for that you're ready for that I
I think I have the right makeup I there
aren't fortunately for my job prospects
there aren't a lot of people that are
really ready for something like that but
I happen to to continue to kind of pay
that path okay let's we're gonna start
go back to that one of the okay so I
want to get back to what exactly what we
were talking about a button that weren't
that I feel were not ready to for space
travel so this guy is living up there
for a year his body deteriorates why
yeah when you are on the International
Space Station you are in something
called microgravity it's not called
zero-g
the you do have some very small forces
from the International Space Station not
being in a perfect orbit but but
effectively you're in zero gravity and
suddenly you don't need your legs as
much Oh God we're walking around is by
petal by petal species bring a lot of
force our legs exactly our weight so was
he not exercising up there or is that a
thing you exercise a lot actually do you
think he wasn't exercising oh oh he was
okay okay
the issue is even when we're sleeping
were you know exercising in a way
because we're putting some weights
oh you're right wow this guy's okay
right and walking or running and we can
do this later but I'm running a marathon
in a couple weeks
oh that puts a lot of strain on your
body that you wouldn't otherwise it'd
feel in space okay okay even when you're
exercising you're not is you're not
because value right because part of the
exercising the the what is that the
resistance that gravity is putting on
you is helping you exercise you exercise
actually twice as much to get the same
workout pretty much look at me yeah
right now imagine imagine here at the
gym and you're about to do a squat right
a lot of people when they're first
starting out it's hard for me to imagine
that imagine you're doing it I'm only
teasing but go on yeah but a lot of
people don't use weights right they're
just using their body weight when
they're doing a squat but that's what
like yoga and like those like those cat
aesthetic exercises where you're like
you know you know you're doing you know
you're doing all that kind of nonsense
that's you're using your body weight
exactly okay and besides the flexibility
advantages of those sorts of exercises
you really need your body weight to do
the work you don't have that in space
and so there's no core workout you
suddenly you you have to be contorted
yourself in different ways and getting
assistance for machines to actually get
the same workout oh wow
and so they do actually have machines
for this a tribe they have trouble out
one treadmill in the International Space
Station and you actually are hooked down
into it and so it pretends like you're
using some sort of downward force okay I
have so many questions and I and guys
I'm not cutting him off okay I'm just
asking more questions
bilenda questions alright saw it because
some people like okay
sci-fi movies okay a lot of it is
obviously it's just science fiction but
it is based off like you know people
thinking that hopefully technology will
get to this point all right totally all
right so when you're watching this
there's always some sort of fake gravity
you know like that like every space
movie the the the what do you call it
the design of a spaceship there's some
circular thing that's on it and it's
moving like this on this big net usually
in our minds is like oh that's what's
creating the gravity you're right okay
you're totally right alright so why
aren't they doing that on the space
station like how can we don't have
artificial gravity to help with this
problem because there are easier easier
solutions that don't look as Hollywood
if you just rotate the space shuttle
this way uh-huh
you can do the same thing oh really so
you don't need a giant wheel no it also
moving parts are difficult for
liability if it breaks you're messed up
and then and then in space - it doesn't
matter there's no up there's no down
because like so they could just spin as
long as year cuz if you're on the thing
that's going like this you're always
gonna feel like you're standing up right
exactly it's called normal force and
yeah that's what it effectively feel as
our gravity
okay so why aren't they why isn't there
artificial gravity on the space station
like why why didn't they do that will
that solve the problem that's what I'm
asking - I think part of the design for
the International Space Station is to
try to get our astronauts or
physiological test specimens to
experience as much pure space travel as
possible gotcha
and if we're essentially faking it by by
assisting them into experiencing
something more similar to earth we've
cut our science and a half uh-oh
that's I totally get what you mean so
then also they're not gonna have gravity
there also because they're doing like
medical experiments in space
- to see if no gravity will help with
like curing cancer or weight right the
issues that Scott Kelly went through are
horrible for him temporarily but
ultimately it's very beneficial for
science how is he now he's fine he's
he's back it took him a few months oh so
you can't recover from these things
they're here do not shrink there there
are a few things that they're permanent
it mostly related to eyesight oh no your
your eyes actually elongate a little bit
in microgravity and so typically your
vision is slightly worse I after you
come back and theory may be like if
aliens came from long distances do you
think that the microgravity has changed
their body in a way that that's why they
maybe maybe they started off in a
humanoid and then from this long stay
space travel their eyes got big that's
woven and then they come and look this
sounds like a good plot for a movie yeah
next door
because I could so all right what am I
really asking like so what when are we
gonna be able to then to travel 26
months in space and did not have these
crazy effects on the body because when
you get there you're gonna have a lot to
do and how you get it you're gonna be
sick right and there are other ways of
getting sick too from the radiation I
talked about the radiation or tell us
about that earth is a beautiful thing we
we are very well made for Earth because
if you stand out in the Sun too long
you're gonna get a suntan right and if
you eat a little longer you'll get
sunburned and then if you do that for
years you might you know use your
chances of cancer right you're saying
even on earth the radiation is dangerous
right and we have this beautiful thing
called the ozone layer which is very
important and when you protect it and
that keeps us from getting those
radiative effects quicker places like
the moon for instance or Mars have very
very little atmosphere and the they
practically have no ozone layer so the
idea of getting a suntan happens almost
instantaneously without the right
protection okay while you're in space
right for instance if you don't have a
like a protection around your spaceship
or a spacesuit mmm-hmm you you're
exposed to that radiation directly and
that could be horrible so it's not even
just cuz like when every time all my
knowledge is just dumb space movies
which is good though I think the
honestly that movies do a fantastic job
there are some business the mark but
this part you're talking about though
they never acknowledge in space mine my
movie experience is always when you're
in space you freeze like they always
like you know you know I mean they
always say a person is like takes their
helmet off and then they just instantly
freeze is that true oh that's one of
those interesting things to me about
space and I think it took me actually
until college to learn this one but as
morbid as it is the way you die if your
space it comes off is multi-step and you
don't die right away
oh really it's a
the the biggest the the first thing that
hits you is the pressure differential
you essentially get got you it's as if a
vacuum comes at you at every orifice and
you've a sense you're removed of
everything liquid so namely everything
inside here oh it's a cuz we're like 80%
water right or something like that yeah
yeah a lot of water a lot of organs that
are easily accessible through the mouth
any ears and nose and essentially
everything all that has to come out
and so you are typically alive for a few
seconds before you you know lose enough
blood to pass out and die but it's a
horrible death oh you're all your
liquids get sucked out of your body and
see that that's not top five horrible
damage and then after that's all done
then you freeze oh [ __ ] okay all right
so all right so the radiation is the
issue so then all right so therefore
going to space travel we're worried
about zero gravity on the body and so
just a couple more two notes on that
okay go you're because you are now
lighter effectively you're it's as if
you're in a baby's body I you imagine
like you have a 15 pound infant that
becomes you you are as you feel like it
effectively like you're this big infant
and and suddenly your body's like well
why do I need calves the size and why do
I need arms this large gotcha
everything sort of shrink so so you're
saying there's like a like a quick
evolution exactly okay instant evolution
it's as if your body says well no longer
my X pounds I'm actually like 15 20
pounds right and and what happens is
your heart church to shrink because you
don't need it you don't need as much
it's a pump blood I also your your bones
also become more narrow and so you have
this weakening as emcee of your entire
skeleton but your body says it's okay
because you are lighter you're
effectively lighter right so if you were
born in space and you live to like
you're a how old are you I'm 25
if look if you lived if you were born in
space and you lived in space to you were
25
if we brought you to earth you wouldn't
even be able to handle it huh it would
be a challenge you would you would
instantly have to go into a wheelchair
and that's actually what they do with
astronauts when they come back from long
missions you are your mandate to go into
a wheelchair for a little bit and go
into rehab because your bones don't
you're much more fragile and you can
fracture things very easily and this is
worth it to you absolutely all right all
right I just want to make sure okay so
now we so we're worried about what
happens to the body we're worried about
the radiation and we haven't even got to
our destination yet exactly it's not I
mean some people asked like you know how
can we haven't gone back to the moon how
can we have any one Mars it's been
decades yeah but we're kind of starting
to understand the reasons it's it's not
easy it's not easy do you think it did
knowing the level of technology of like
the Apollo missions do you look at look
at that now and be like is it more
amazing to think about what they did now
because of how advanced technology is
now I I definitely that stance I think a
lot of people are more critical or
negative and like how come we haven't
done more since then but honestly we it
was amazing we got there when we did
because the ignorance was bliss
apparently huh it's it's I mean the fact
we a Buzz Aldrin alive today and he's
able to share stories of him walking on
the moon's unbelievable if you believe
that that really happened right oh gosh
yeah I'm not a I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but you you're certain that we
went to the moon yeah okay because
you've worked for NASA you've worked for
SpaceX also worked for Virgin Galactic
Virgin God I didn't even know about what
Virgin Galactic is that the competitor
to SpaceX not exactly Richard Branson is
the is the chairman of Virgin Galactic
and they along with a company called
Blue Origin which Jeff Bezos owns are
trying to send people like you and me
but for a lot of money to visit space
for short periods of time just for
recreational so do you think the future
of space travel and space technology
will be in the hands of the private
sector
for it for it to beat for it to advance
to the level that we want to get to for
you know the science fiction movie
version of what space travel should be
or could be it definitely looks that way
but but not alone like we still need
some sort of input from NASA again
SpaceX and Blue Origin other
organizations like this would agree that
places like NASA are really needed to to
keep to keep the funding alive and the
dreams alive right but but certainly
places like SpaceX are are putting in
most of the effort and and making those
headway here they are I love looking at
SpaceX stuff like I saw he even got me a
little hat right you are oh yeah yeah
look at this I got my little space X hat
now thank you like I like that that
reusable rocket saying I was following
that for a while but it just it's so
crazy like how excited everybody was
that that you know that rocket landed
again but it's like so where is the
technology right now of what spaceships
like how far are we away away from like
either it being docked at a space
station or being able to just take off
from Earth and then you know you know my
guy like x-men you know we have like a
like a like the shape of a plane is for
earth but it doesn't necessarily work in
space right exactly because earth has
atmosphere a plane has wings because we
can sit on the air in space you don't
you don't have that you have to use your
engines to actually do maneuver right
right right
and it but in terms of time I think
we're within years of seeing actual are
like finished architectures that are
ready for places like Mars I mean the
thing we're like the it takes off from
Earth and then or whatever and then it
can land on Mars and it take off from
Mars and come back right we won't see
that Nisshin
I don't believe until the 30s but but in
the 20s I am pretty certain that we're
at the pace where we'll actually see the
vehicles that are
ready to do this mission being tested in
full and what are those what are those
aircraft not gonna look like what are
they what do you thing they're gonna
look like can they be can they look like
anything can they just you know are they
gonna be as their certain shapes that's
conducive for space travel more than you
know what we think like is it circular
is it like a box is it doesn't still
have to be aerodynamic like what what is
the best shape for to travel the there
really are two big phases of flights
that you have to design for leaving an
atmospheric body namely earth because we
have atmosphere you you can't just
design a bus right right exactly so it
has to be aerodynamic as the aerodynamic
all right but once you leave the
atmosphere it really doesn't have to be
you can be a cube if you wanted to in
fact a lot of satellites because they
spend their life in space alone or
cubicle well then do you think that when
we start to travel that the ship to go
up to the space station is gonna be
aerodynamic but whatever the ship is
it's gonna be traveling to Mars it's
gonna be because like we're not gonna go
you're not gonna need 26 months in a in
a cockpit right it's gonna have to be
something that like you could get in it
gets sort of roam around
you're right do you think you're right
and I'm also speaking from the knowledge
that we do have these architectures
already designed these spacecraft are
are pretty much done I'll be ready to go
there's there's one through SpaceX
called called a starship and there's one
through NASA called SLS or Space Launch
System and and these are two different
designs that are ready to take us to
Mars and SpaceX at least right now is
actively testing their their vehicle but
they have to build it in space right
it's built actually in Florida in Texas
oh how they gonna get it to space I it's
it has many large engines called raptor
attached to the bottom of it and and
essentially it propels itself just into
space oh so we asked okay so we actually
can't take off from Earth with an intact
spaceship and get it to spare
still gonna have those kind of rockets
that help it and then they break off the
it does go in stages the first stage is
predominantly fuel and so once we burn
out of that fuel that that stage falls
away and then you're left with
essentially the Greyhound bus which is a
spaceship that is it's it's ash it's
astronaut ready such that it's it's no
five-star hotel right right right right
but you're going for that exactly but
you're also no room service on the went
to this later I'd you played a pilot I'm
and I am a pilot so you want to fly well
we all astronauts have to be able to do
everything right exactly not like a
science team even the science guy that
like the guy that's like the ecolodge
the agriculture guy he's got to know how
to fly right okay absolutely yeah and
yeah but keep in mind though that's a
that aerodynamic part doesn't completely
go away just because you left earth
because two things if land on Mars and
you've come back earth okay what true
okay so all right
going to Mars though like like what are
they what they're trying to like
terraform Mars right isn't that like you
know like from a like the movie aliens
you know they have this big atmosphere
thing you know like is that something
that we should be thinking about doing
now before we even send the the thing
over there like aren't they trying to
like send like you know missiles and
have to blow the place up or what's that
whole thing okay I'm not saying it right
but you can you kill me it's awesome
like if like that should be like common
knowledge but unfortunately it's not I
mean I there are teams at NASA SpaceX
and other companies as well that are
working on these so working toward the
solutions trying to find ways of quick
question though about that are they
working together at all
or is this like oh we're gonna you know
it's like we're trying to do this on our
own we're gonna is there like a space
race amongst those come
the space race would be from private
company private company to private
company uh-huh but a lot of that is
trying to get government dollars for
funding NASA they they're going to pick
sides with whoever they believe the most
but they'll likely or they are also
hedging their bets by funding multiple
companies as well
blends in who's in the lead do you think
it's hard as private companies go in
terms of getting us to Mars SpaceX is is
the leader but NASA independently is
making quite a bit of headway with SLS I
know we got off track here but this is
so interesting to me are the companies
fighting for young minds like yourself
it's it's not a bad working it's not a
bad environment to be to be an aerospace
engineering student right now yeah yeah
absolutely
we they're the recruiting must be like
you know you come as may sex
come to gap you know come to NASA is it
like if they're recruiting like you know
heavy it were definitely seeing
reemergence it seemed like there were a
generation that was it was less
desirable to be in a aerospace
engineering student like it was in the
60s 70s in the 80s with the Space
Shuttle development program took some
time off and and we're definitely seeing
that come back again so absolutely there
are there companies like SpaceX Blue
Origin Virgin Galactic many others that
are trying to get people who I was gonna
say like I did I never hear too many
people say like oh I want to be an
astronaut that used to be a thing but
there seems to be more movies coming on
right now like damar I love the Martian
I love that move on one yeah and just
the the book is great you know what I
mean I got the audiobook and I watched a
movie cuz I saw the movie I was like I
wanna and it's so techie that book right
it's you know I mean it's so techie
which gave it some authenticity you know
what I mean and I'd really enjoyed that
about the book and I thought wow like
how far aware we are from that kind of
thing you know so that's why where I had
you on because I loved how you were
talking about it and your interest in
being like one of the first people to go
tomorrow
and timing works out decently well too
if if we take my prediction as fact
which 2034 let's say that's the year
that human step foot on Mars uh-huh we
want those individuals to be in there
probably late 30s early 40s why why we
want people that are a little bit
seasoned as far as astronauts in
training maybe they've been to space a
couple of times and by the way typically
astronauts are selected in their late
20s early 30s and and so someone in
they're in their late 30s early 40s will
have had some experience and those are
likely going to be the the age of
individual sent on that first mission
mmm and so since the 2034 is 15 years
from now you know you'll be in 40
something years old I'm talking about
people of today in their mid-20s Wow
okay are they so this is like this is
your dream this is your goal you know
this is like you're like I have to do
this how close to you to actually just
go into space just on like a random
mission so NASA sends out their
applications every four years right now
it used to be every year I but lately
it's been every four years and the last
one was three three years ago so it
looks is looking like something around
next summer is when there'll be a
national now spin you'll hear it
on every news station saying NASA is
seeking astronauts and people like
myself will who are taking it very
seriously will will research the right
people and apply and also you're moving
and shaking right now your your your
your make you're building relationships
you're trying to be the one to be like
hey I want to take pick me pick me right
you can imagine there's a lot of
competition of course and fortunately
most the people who do end up applying
to be an astronaut are not really in the
running these are people who who maybe
have want to be national for a long time
but maybe you don't understand what the
job really entails but there there are
hundreds I would say of individuals who
are vying for a dozen spots
oh wow damn so you wow that's a that's a
lot like that's so so I mean this seems
like a dumb question but you'd be hugely
disappointed if you never get to go to
space then I I'm pretty sure I'll go to
space in my lifetime I whether I'll work
in space as a NASA astronaut that
remains to be seen
I that would be preferred but they
actually do have opportunities now where
you know you can even send your ashes to
space for a couple thousand dollars so
really anyone can get to space and I
will be in space in my in some some pure
points my ashes will at least but of
course I prefer to work there okay so
let's get back to terraforming Mars yep
okay so how would that how would they go
excuse me how did they go about this and
do you think that's something that
should be started before we do even get
there and is that even possible
it's we took this a little bit on
impulsive but like the the first couple
missions even the first few missions
will really be can we do this is this
possible with our current technology and
it was doing to our humans and and so
those that handful of people who will go
on whatever vehicle takes us there and
by the way it will be a two-way mission
there was a proposal for a one-way
mission that's more on the air of
science fiction but one way mission
meaning like these people are gonna go
and then they're gonna die yeah right
exactly and and there's there are
individuals out there who believe
they're on they're selected for that
one-way trip but it will never happen
right right we're just just it just yeah
we wouldn't want to do that yeah but you
know let's say in the 2030s we go on
this two-way mission the first few times
we do this by the way there I mentioned
there are twenty six months cycles so
even if we go a few times that take
that's going to take seven years it's
complete just a few missions but you're
right right our seven-year so even in a
whole decade we've gone there for top
four
so maybe 20 people have been there and
by that point let's say after a decade
of successes you know granted we were
making progress and so you're saying
just even flying to Mars getting there
and just turning right back around that
would be a huge success it would be the
nominal mission right that's the guess
the reasonable goal we won't go until we
believe that it is going to be the
likely outcome but it's a it certainly
will be celebrated
you know the people in the science world
absolutely the amount of understanding
we'll get from that first mission will
be incredible and those individuals will
become heroes would you go with it on
that first mission would they go with
the idea of landing on Mars
absolutely okay okay yeah all right but
okay how about this
what about the whole like you know you
know the putting people to sleep chamber
things you know like is that is that
something that is even considered or is
that all science fiction I think the
things in the room of science fiction
that's something that would never happen
where you're putting people in cryo that
you know cryo whatever that is and you
know they're you know and then then they
wake up we're at Mars you know you know
they come out of the thing you know I
think the most real medicine that we
could apply for that is putting someone
in a coma for the six months even close
to that being a real thing of putting
people in a thing that will be suspended
animation right I you would need a lot
of confidence in in that procedure to
put someone into a coma wake them up in
time for them to get ready for their
mission that it's not that it's
impossible it's definitely possible but
but for our first Mars missions I would
be shocked well I guess my real question
is what I'm asking is is that a
technology that is actually being
pursued I'm sure there's a team or two
out there working on this but I would
say this would be smaller potatoes
because that would be something that
could be used even here yeah yeah people
would be using that'd be like
go to sleep wake me up in a hundred
years you know that be people wanting to
do that right you know really that's a
whole other can of worms okay so in
terms of like okay so you're saying that
the first missions are gonna be just
flying to Mars landing taking off
getting some rock samples you know and
all that stuff well you know put an
American flag your your although you you
are forced to stay a little bit because
and by a little bit I mean months oh
because the the we have to the whole
straight line thing or the little little
arc has to be was lined up again for the
earth exactly okay and Earth and Mars
align every 26 months it takes about
nine months to get there it's nine
months to come back and so you you have
a remainder of 8 months that you should
probably just some good science on Mars
take advantage your time on there and
now are we able to survive for eight
months water air food because isn't that
the main those are the right that's the
three things there and we have the
technology to produce these things
outside of Earth produce we have the
technology whether you'd want to bring
something that could do that and it
would fit inside the ship
that's probably unlikely right now but
what you would do though is you know
bring enough water and food for that
mission with some contingency as far as
far as war goes there are also methods
that astronauts use currently to recycle
their water in ways that we don't really
do on earth for instance like what yeah
it you're an and all right they they
actually drink through and urine on in
space they purify it
they they they run through any filters
but you are really using everything you
bring up with you as much as you can and
right be being an astronaut is in a
Martian movie like you know he used the
human booboo to like potatoes that kind
of stuff are they using that's what
we're gonna have to end up doing I mean
that might be on the scrappy side but
oh [ __ ] potatoes are coming in the near
future right but something along those
lines is not out of okay but you still
haven't really explained to me how well
what like so how we going to how are we
gonna have enough air like is that gonna
be like a science thing or they we're
gonna be creating the air you know like
oxygen
you know hydrogen whatever how are we
how are we gonna have enough air for
twenty six months to breathe they can
have to have twenty six months to air
right right but I keep in mind that you
can also bring compressed air okay I
imagine like a scuba diver would have
enough air for that person four hours
you can imagine that well how big is
that tank gonna be the twenty six month
tank I mean for point a large I don't
have that number of hand but you're
going to need a bring enough oxygen and
in water for your individuals not to say
there won't be machines as well that
will be recyclers and and try to reuse
Oh to the co2 that we breathe out and
then turn that back into that kind of
thing you associate the molecules to
where you can use the oxygen they're
gonna be a thing with they're gonna be
plants in the the ship to like you know
to create oxygen you know I mean like
you know that whole hard to say this is
like I just don't think this slightly so
what you're what you're saying to me
right now is that the science isn't
there yet like we're not it doesn't
sound practical to go to Mars it's it
isn't practical but but people working
on it know that that's what they're
trying to figure out right and they're
they're trying to do not necessary try
to make it practical right now they're
trying to make it plausible plausible
okay because it's just that just the air
thing alone just sounds crazy to me ya
know just like I don't know how I didn't
you know you watch science fiction
movies and you go well how does the
enterprise like what you know
what does the air come from like what do
they do there must be some air machine
you know there to create in it you know
whatever whatever you might think that
is so but like in real life we're saying
oh yeah we're gonna have
take enough water but they we can do the
recycling but they're still gonna be
like a big tank of water that has to go
with them right and then we're gonna
have to take the food and the air and
I'm thinking that air part trips me out
like have it to take you know enough air
for twenty six months to Mars I mean
you're absolutely I'm sure they'll take
the lessons learned from the
International Space Station I'm not
exactly sure how they do it up there
yeah what do they do up there exactly I
I don't know the exact answer is there
like some like air run like you know
there comes the air I mean it's possible
if they need compressed air for
especially for experiments they probably
would bring it with them Wow what is it
what what happened this is this is gonna
sound like a stupid question but like so
what about farting in space like is that
gas used to are they recycling that or
that is that just is is that a problem
if you're like in a space station and
somebody farts and that is like just you
know what what happens to that so what
that is you're producing methane yeah
ironically methane is the fuel used to
propel our rockets to Mars oh wow so
maybe when somebody has like a it'd be
great if there's like a tube and every
time somebody had to fart you had to
like do your part and like you know you
have to fart into that tube and it's the
fart is sucked into a that would be away
right let's say you're stuck if they're
stuck and we ran out of fuel that it's
like so in this eight months that
they're there everybody has to fart into
this I think there's some science in
that we could have an extra millisecond
of propulsion sure okay you're telling
me that if eight astronauts farting for
eight months that's science that's not
enough gas to get what you say they
would do okay I guess the question would
be like you nerds out there okay whoever
could figure it out this how many farts
would it take and we're gonna say nice
comments in the section for that one I
just want to know how much methane a
human methane would it take to propel a
rocket okay yeah I can tell you right
now
it's gonna be mm loss I love how I love
how well you're taking the question
serious but half and half like but
you're like but isn't there a part of
you that's like it's all science right I
mean I know the number two like you need
leaders like like many many leaders
kilolitres even to really have a big
difference in your fuel supply okay and
astronauts can't if there was a fuel
problem right don't expect hit the
Saviour three pages of stuff just to see
if I missed out on anything I love like
he has his background here so all right
so you model kit that's how you started
yeah I was a six year old kid my parents
were kind of throwing little kits at me
they weren't really sure what would
stick but they could tell I was a stem
oriented student science technology
engineering math and I remember they
gave me a good geology kid and it was
okay I I think I made it in a couple
days and it was it was fun but it wasn't
like super into it right my parents gave
me a an electric circuits kit I like
working with batteries and wires and
lights and I like that a little bit
better but I keep in mind I was six
years old I don't know how this stuff
worked at the time so it was like it was
tinkering but then I remember my dad and
I went to her local park launched this
little model rocket I was just like you
were like this is it six-year-old me it
was like I don't know what I just saw
but I want to see that again
wow that's dope that's just a message
out there to parents is like you know
give your kid a bunch of stuff until
that one clicks all right yeah you know
who knows what I've been doing if I
would have ultimately found this still
or it's hard to say yeah wow that that
that just you know my mom's
was sort of like that she didn't give me
like space stuff but it was like you
know if I if I if she felt I was
interested in something it should be
like okay you want to do that let me let
me let me look into it you know like you
know hey maybe you should take a class
everybody should go over here and do
that that's like exploration is super
important so you like some people even
you know into their adulthood are still
looking for what their passions are in
yeah exactly and I think they're looking
they're still looking for the passions
because obviously they haven't found it
right you know and it's just like what
do I really want to do and it's just
like Explorer figure things out right
sorry I sometimes I wonder if I was
fortunate that I had this inherent
interest in aerospace or automatically
and eventually would have found it no
matter what right or really it was just
essentially I had the right parents to
really take in any eggs huge stakes yeah
Wow what do you think it is as a
scientist I mean yeah I I love my
parents and and they are amazing and
it's interesting because they they don't
come from a scientific or engineering
background my dad's a writer and my
mom's a French teacher so very
humanities just a nerd house from heaven
right here Thanksgiving dinner though
okay I just want to hear the
conversations at your Thanksgiving table
riveting about your personality uh you
know yeah like would you consider
yourself socially awkward at all
or do you eat are you comfortable in
social settings
I think do myself is a pretty strong
extroverts yeah yeah I do you think I'm
I mean how you describe like is a good
nerd like I definitely enjoy telling
stories that happen to be more academic
but I I would like to think that I I'm
quite sociable and listen I'm a nerd
okay I love talking about Star Trek Star
Wars I'm a nerd about the things that I
like and like you know I want I go into
things about like you know like Avengers
endgame for instance you know I'm
where I go all duty you know I like
playing Call of Duty yeah I'm a nerd but
like like Avengers end game like you
know this is something that ruined the
movie for me is that you know so Hawkeye
in the beginning of the movie
his family disappears and I'm like oh
that happened in Wakanda in Africa how
was it daylight in both places right see
I'm a nerd like that like you know where
I'm like what's the time zone or Wakanda
that this farm and wherever he is both
daylight you know I mean like that's
like a thing where I go come on
filmmaker situational I'm a nerd so like
nerd when I say I say it fondly of you
like you know that like this [ __ ] this
is a nerd [ __ ] right here this podcast I
mean like three pages of my background
for him this is what I'm talking about
like this is like I don't mean like that
kind of what I mean I mean to say is
like you know you don't seem like like
yeah you are unusual but the way you're
you very open and I outgoing so I guess
that's that I guess that you you've
balanced it too but I would I don't I
don't want to say you have an odd
personality and that's not necessarily
the word I want to use uniques kind of
yeah overplay yes yes I wouldn't call it
unique either but it's like you know
like like like if you told me you had
autism or you had like a slight I
wouldn't be surprised but there is you
know there is like a certain manner that
you have a certain light wave going
about things that I did I just go like
is that inherent to people that go into
science and like you find it like I'm
sure there's a lot of like like I don't
want to say weirdos that you work with
but there are people that I'm sure that
have quirks you have quirks as I said
I'm trying to like you're quirky dude
but at the same time you're still like a
cool nerd you know you're probably the
most popular dude of all the nerds you
know the nerd girls must love you
they're just like oh you know cuz you go
you're like if a jock and a nerd
combined in a second you know like the
fly you know there was like a jock and a
nerd inside the chamber then they get
teleported
you combine but like so you don't you've
never had like any kind of social
awkward interactions obviously you have
you have a mother and father that loved
you greatly they pushed you towards
things so I guess that that's why you
are so personable I guess right I think
as far as academics go I've found myself
in a more academic setting for friends
as well so like I feel like my own
friend group feels like a lot of people
like me got you guys and more
comfortable with people there that you
can just you know rattle off something
about aerospace and they're like oh I
totally know I as long as the person's
willing to listen I'm great I interact
I'm a huge storyteller and I love
teaching people and I've taught classes
before I so as long as someone's willing
to learn and listen and and be patient
I'm I love that yeah I can tell you were
really excited to be on this just like I
want to talk about stuff yeah that's
great man
I just think that I hope that you do get
to go to Mars you know I really do
because it's just it's just such a
strange like we're in a time right now
that people are afraid of technology
we're not we're not we haven't accepted
it yet like like the self-driving cars
like I think the thing that's holding us
back from self-driving cars is our own
fear and ignorance of the technology
because if we were to braced it more
than would be like okay this is good
it's cuz it's gonna happen there's gonna
be a time when no one's gonna be driving
anymore do you think that I do I think
in our own lifetime yeah I think so too
I think and I think like 10 years you
know it's gonna be all electric hydrogen
cars you know we're not gonna be doing
we're not even gonna have to get out of
the car it's gonna be like a little
robot it's gonna be putting it you know
into your car to fill you up and you
you're gone you know with little cabins
and stuff like that I mean to your point
also about the uncertainty about the
future of autonomous vehicles look at
Tesla stock like the thing is super wild
and yeah and of course part of that is
is because the goals are very ambitious
and they're
- sure what the future may bring of that
specific company still there are a lot
of opinions that go into the future of
autonomous vehicles and as is very much
shown in the price doing this yeah but
like but then the infrastructure isn't
necessarily in place yet - like like for
instance hydrogen vehicles like we
easily could be go all hydrogen already
but we just don't have the
infrastructure in place it's just gas
stations are everywhere like you know we
don't people are but isn't there like
some kind of evil up with electric cars
there's some new phobia now that is
crowding or what it's called I'm sure it
has a name you know that you know what
I'm talking about how people think their
cards gonna ruin their so scared that
their cards gonna like you know run out
of electricity that there are fearful
whatever there's a new phobia you know
so that we're creating oh and I love the
videos on YouTube of people the older
generation stepping into their grandkids
Tesla and just going like what is
spaceship that I'm in yeah it is pretty
amazing it's just amazing that we
haven't already gone all-electric or or
whatever kind of technology got gone
away from the I will say though the this
year we've seen almost every major car
company realize that electric is this is
where we're going is we're going and and
I think somewhere in Europe there was a
major car show and and it it was
apparent that everyone's trying to find
the new Model S right right so what are
you like what like what um what do you
what do you what's your hobbies you know
like you know like I mean are you a nerd
guy in terms of comic books movies like
are you like are you excited about the
new Star Wars is that when you are like
okay look as the comic or somebody
that's in the entertainment business
when I watch a movie if I'm not really
interested in the movie I find myself
like looking at the lighting or like ah
that joke didn't play I when you go
watch Star Wars are you always like
that's not possible oh that's [ __ ]
that's never gonna there's no light
space light speed and I or can you just
enjoy it can you
suspend your disbelief it's funny if the
movie is trying to take themselves
seriously and tries to pretend the
physics is perfect uh-huh that's when I
think I'll be like like talking to my
neighbor all right could you go get your
nerd friends and you guys are just in
the theater but there are movies like an
Astra that just came out uh-huh and they
don't pretend like the physics is
perfect they they're going into it for
you know for the thrill of another space
movie right but also trying to entertain
and realize that this is coming out of
Hollywood and and Brad Pitt's character
isn't trying to be like Mark Watney
right it's I haven't seen the movie yet
but I really want to see it it's a I'm
excited it's cuz I like it because you
you can go into it even if you know the
physics you can go into it ready to be
entertained not trying to critique but
so but I even with your answer you
critique I could tell that you are you
and you're like you're in Star Wars
being like come on guys it's like it's
Lightspeed even possible for humans
probably not right and why is that
II the amount of energy that would take
something of our mass to accelerate to
Lightspeed is is insane so we'd be
crushed in the process like we wouldn't
even be able to survive inside the thing
if you if you're accelerated slowly
enough you could do it you physically
could do it um we would see huge changes
to our physiology you shrink faster you
go oh wow and time would change relative
to the an observer which is kind of wild
oh like that movie did you like what was
that one with Matthew McConaughey yeah
did you see that one it was like oh this
science is so if it was that science
close to like you were like oh they're
doing this right I think for the end
when it was all like you know that was
just science fiction that part but I
talk about the wit to travel like you
know like we're one minute here is like
20 years someplace else was all that
accurate I think this is like perfect
practically this would be well beyond
our lifetimes but like the idea of a
creation of a wormhole and to get into
different universe or two different
galaxies even these are things that are
theoretically possible but whether
humans will ever be able to do that I
don't know I love like you're so smug
about it you know I mean you're just
like I actually want to come to a movie
with you and your friends not with an
astronaut but I want to sit in the back
of you guys I just want to take notes
and feel how like so but anyways you say
you do love science fiction movies
absolutely you're you're going but as
far as like hobbies you bring up your ID
I think my pastimes wouldn't be focused
in the movie theater I whatever they are
you know I I'm I'm a big time adventure
honestly a little bit of adrenaline
junkie I want to go to space man what
are you talking about that's already
added rental in junkie you want to be a
40 year old going to Mars it's not like
a crazy person if you think about it
like that
yeah it's you can imagine the people
with the quote right stuff right are
people that are doing these hide rentals
and things down here on earth and really
preparing themselves for that kind of
hide rental in Mission you want a rock
climb and things like that yeah so I fly
little planes out here Oh Santa Monica
oh that's right cuz you have to be a
pilot Jesus look at you so I'm probably
a couple couple months a month away from
being apologizing but you could just fly
on your own yep and I and I have flown
alone a few times flew to San Diego I've
flown to Malibu Wow yeah it would just
be disappointing if you just ended up
that guy's a Delta Airlines pilot you're
like 40 70 you're like welcome to Delta
thank you for flying you have many
choices in your hairline I'll leave that
to you oh you think I'm I'm already in
my 40s I promise opposed to be ready to
go tomorrow
how disappointing would you be if you
saw me like I'm like right now lady
there's some secret Latino company
Amazon guy has been secretly building if
I can face thing and he's just like
taking volunteers I would love it I was
like I can't believe I got to meet the
guy who went to Mars you know what
that's something I do like about you you
have a very positive outlook on things
you I do find you to be a very
personable person I didn't mean I don't
want it I didn't mean to insult you or
anything like that about you know you
just have like a very different
personality you know I mean what it is
is I can't put my finger on it I know I
think about it more what it is is like
you actually don't fall into any of the
stereotypes so it's like oh and I want
you to know I got a beard fly a plane
I'm like no you should have all of this
you're like you're like you're like -
you're like a millennial nerd this is
great you know you're around Logan Paul
and you're who is this guy
but it's great stuff man you know I look
forward to see what's going on in your
future you know we've been this is like
I can't believe how long we've been
target like this so I hope people find
this interesting because I found it
interesting that's why you're my first
non-entertainment guest by the way first
hopefully not last yeah I know I wonder
I was I want to clean easy to open this
up you know so the things that I find
interesting and I just I just found you
to be so interesting when you were
talking about the Mars you were so into
it I was like oh this guy's actually
you're gonna get
I fully believe 100% that you're gonna
get to Mars man you're gonna get to Mars
and you know so this is like few kids
out there dream big right absolutely you
know yeah don't don't don't let your
six-year-old dreams just come to an end
like oh I love that
you know shirt yeah and of course we all
need to be realistic right like you know
I was like my brother's preschool I have
a two-year brother who's two years
younger than me and I remember when when
he was in preschool one of the funniest
things was a girl in his class
we're going around saying what they want
to be when they grew up and a girl says
she want to be an elephant to be fair I
don't I don't know we haven't yet we
haven't checked but I have downside she
put those kind of things right like you
know you also want to check yourself at
some point yeah but if you find yourself
being how do you manage your
expectations then for yourself I try to
set as I set goals for myself with
enough time in advance to where I think
I can with the proper preparation reach
them or get Christ but there has to be a
mount there has to be a certain amount
of arrogance that you have to have and
confidence in yourself right often Solis
you know but I mean I just don't think
anybody's great at anything without
having a you believe in yourself yeah
they're happy yeah so like like are you
like what does your brother do like are
you like the one that's like you're the
nerd smart guy you're on you're going to
NASA and SpaceX and he's like what's he
doing he's he's amazing in his own way i
he's more of a Salesman actually he's a
he has skills that I don't have like he
can get someone to buy a watch off his
wrist whereas I would have a big time
big trouble kind of doing that and and
he actually found a place on YouTube
when he was a teenager I I never really
put much effort into that oh wow okay so
that's that's great and you get you got
you clothes getting closer you know I
think you said your whole childhood
right now I see it in front of me right
now that you guys I can see you guys you
guys were complete opposites we see the
bully brother you know then you guys now
you guys are as you get older you kind
of put that childhood stuff behind and
now you're like seeing each other for
like you know for what you guys offer to
each other now right it took us to be
adults to really be able be like much
closer I yeah you're right though we
were very different interests growing up
and Here I am trying to explain physics
and if someone doesn't want to hear
physics
that's not gonna go very far oh and you
just yeah then you just yeah I could
think that must have been frustrating
yeah and then I just find your friends
like your nerd circle that's fixed no
that's great bad I just that's like
that's like you did you know what I feel
like there's gonna be movies made about
you you know right and you're you're
already doing that yeah but I'm not I
mean it's not about me you know I mean
like who would play you who would you
want to play you it's funny that there
is a there's an actor named Alexander
Gould I and he does look like me or I
look like him I'm not sure I he and I
are about the same age he's the guy who
was the voice of Nemo oh really
I believe he was I think he was like 7
years old when he did this and he and I
as 7 year olds look identical
oh I'm then sure enough growing up maybe
up until age like 20 we were at the same
person I actually had a friend in high
school I'm gonna have to put that up I'm
gonna have to like put that up right
there you never really grew any facial
hair so now we don't look so similar
right but you B's my doppelganger okay I
was trying to stop but I you keep making
me want to ask but when when did you
come into your coolness you know there's
a partner then well you know what I you
know what I'm talking about like there
there's a there's a when I guess it's
like when was the moment that you became
completely comfortable with yourself
okay I okay I I think getting a little
bit more deep I was obese as a child ah
see here we go and and I end up going
through some sort of you know body
transformation when I was 9 and I was
all very young and I essentially was a
fat kid at school and picked on and so I
definitely have a soft spot in my heart
for for people you know it's a situation
people getting bullied in that kind of
stuff right so then when did you make
the transformation that you rely
now I'm gonna take control of my life
and them who's gonna you know I mean I
was really young I you knew at a young
age you were like I'll [ __ ] this fat
[ __ ] I'm tired of it I think it took me
to figure out it's like I mean you know
kind of going back to my favorite things
science once I figured out that being
overweight was unhealthy for me I was
like and there it is yeah there was so
we had nothing to do with anything other
than like oh this is actually unhealthy
I told dude I'm trying to get healthy
right now but I've been I'm working down
I'm working on it and it's because of
what's going on with my mom you know and
I just thought I started looking like oh
this is what leads to dementia and
things like that and you know just you
know inflammation and all these kinds of
things now it's like oh I need to start
taking care of that but it's like the
science of it like this whole thing
about you know feel good about what you
look like is like no no take it from the
scientist when he was 10 years old he
was like oh look at the science like oh
you know what this isn't healthy I mean
I probably need to change this that's
the message that we should be giving
kids and young people you know what I
mean just pisses me off man
well good feed you up but you should
have opened with this kind of stuff this
is like so then so you're telling me it
like 10 11 years old you were like you
took you you made you change you walked
into your parents house it was like
we're vegan I'm not Spencer Taylor so
you then you changed your diet like what
did you do right how did your parents
handle that when you came in you did you
walk in and be like hey we gonna change
all this so let's start getting some get
to sugar out of here no more soda how
did you do it yeah you can imagine it's
tough for a nine-year-old to change
their parents minds right it would
what's in the kitchen but I yeah I
looked online and quite like probably be
the most naive search you could possibly
make how to lose weight great like you
know that's probably been googled by
everyone ever right and and for me I
figured out that okay and reduced my
calories that reduce my fat and and I
probably should measure things and so I
actually found I
I took they figured out some caloric
intake that I should be eating as a
nine-year-old kid I was eating 1,400
plus or minus 100 calories every day
right and I was running and I went from
essentially you know being the slowest
person in my my PE class running a 15
minute mile pretty much walking pace
yeah to just right around 7 minutes one
of the fast dude this what you're
talking about right now cuz the science
[ __ ] it's already amazing what you're
talking about right now it's equally
amazing what you're saying things you're
telling me at nine years old you were
like oh this I don't like this anymore
are you googled how do I lose weight and
you were like oh you know what I'm
eating too many calories right I'm
eating too much I should probably change
that and you changed your life hey you
fat [ __ ] out there hey you people with
your [ __ ] about body shaming and all
this kind of stuff this is how we're
gonna change the world right here
science science Wow
yeah I went from so I'm relatively light
I weigh 138 pounds I know I hate you
know it was from hard work i-i-i was 134
pounds when I was nine years old so I'm
only four pounds heavier now than I was
at nine damn he was a big big boy yeah
Wow
and I dropped from 134 to about 89
pounds okay so but you still had you
still were even when you were skinny
though for a few years you were still a
fat kid in here you're absolutely right
right so when did you not that's so
getting back to my original question
yeah we'll get the hell out of here is
that when did you become comfortable
with yourself it took until ironically
probably the worst time for people in
their childhood but early middle school
was when I really liked how old were you
12 12 man yeah you definitely going to
Mars I for me it was like in my personal
case it was a new set of friends who's a
new middle school I really didn't know
that many people I was able to be you
know no one knew me as the fat kid right
I was able to attend to get a fresh
fresh slate
and I was able to never really you know
use that to make better friends good for
you man that's that that is amazing
right there yeah you just you just like
you got you grew at 12 you were like
okay so now who I want to hang out with
people like me you know you know let me
find these people you found them
and then here you are you know nurture
versus nature right you made yourself
made you were self-made from 9 years old
actually 6 from 6 years old you're
self-made man that was my parents no but
I'm saying the day they day good for
them yeah cuz you said they're not into
science or today they were like we did
it there we go good parent good good
parenting solid family background look
at you yeah you're a decent human being
I can tell you know I really appreciate
it at that about you and I appreciate
you coming on this is like my little
exposure no dude I from the moment I met
you I was like oh this guy's interesting
and so I hope you guys found this
interesting if you did and I really
don't care because I found it
interesting yeah we had a really good
time and you know as other big things
happen I'd love for you to come back and
be like my science segment you know yeah
we could do this again or if even if you
have some other nerds that you wanna
this is good everybody thanks for
watching please subscribe I'm gonna have
all his information so you could follow
his career you're on Instagram and all
that kind of stuff right don't worry
I'll have it all Dillon Dickstein that
must have been hard to having Dickstein
as your name fortunately I was already I
think the key for that and I think a lot
of people can relate to this make fun of
it first bro in closing I have a big
nose
okay yeah whoa because I'm fatter now
but this my nose was this size at 10
okay so so like that was the thing my
whole childhood was like you know you
didn't big nose no matter what school I
went to I was waiting for it Oh big nose
so I used to it was crushing until I got
to high school and I'll never forget I
was in the parking lot with my friends
and like somebody was going on my nose
and then I made
of myself the self-deprecation wins and
then I made fun of like it yeah I
remember saying something like oh yeah
my nose is yeah and I could smell how
stinky you are oh nice and it was just
like a whole thing and it was the last
time it bothered me it was literally the
last time I was like oh this this is it
really doesn't matter you don't I mean
so you like you you figure you probably
13 like okay your dick is in my name
[Laughter]
you're just a model citizen right now
Dylan Dickstein everybody because all
this information will be below future
astronaut future or actually current
astronaut an astronaut yet perspective
perspective astronaut wants to go to
Mars in 15 to 20 years he's been on
Griffin Allah Griffin and please
subscribe and share and thank you for
watching and I'll see you guys next week
[Applause]
[Music]